هذا المشهد يتكرر للعام الثالث على
التوالي يرفع اهالي ضحايا الطائره
الاوكرانيه التي اسقطها الحرس الثوري
الايراني صور احبائهم التي لم تبقى سواها
من حقي ان اعلم كل ما حصل في تلك الليله
الكارثيه انا وعائله الضحايا نطلب معرفه
لماذا ارتكبت هذه الكارثه ومن كان وراءها
انه من حقنا والقتله يجب محاكمتهم
ومعاقبتهم في المحاكم الدوليه وهذا مطلبنا
من العالم ومن النظام الايراني
يخرب بيت جمهوري
الحكومه الكنديه
لاسقاط الطائره طالب الطيران باجراء تحكيم
وتورتكزات في طلب التحكيم على اتفاقيه
مونتريال التي تنظم تسويه الجرائم ضد
الطيران على انه اذا لم يتفق الطرفان خلال
سته اشهر ترفع القضيه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
167 مسافرا بريئا على متن الطائره القادمه
من ايران الى اوكرانيا
كانت عمده وبالتالي عليكم ان تعلنوا
وتعترفوا بان كل الحرس الثوري الايراني
منظمه ارهابيه واذا لم تتعاون معكم ايران
في القضيه يجب ان تتحول الى المحكمه
الجنائيه
هل الضحيه تجمعوا امام مبنى منظمه الطيران
المدني الدولي في مونتريال مطالبين بعدم
الوثوق بايران وتحويل القضيه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
اختلفت مراسم ذكرى سقوط الطائره هذا العام
لانها تزامنت مع احتجاجات تشهدها مدن
ايرانيه عده ارتفعت فيها اصوات المحتاجين
لاسر الضحايا ومطالبين بمحاسبه متورطين
وعلى راسهم خمنائي رفع السعد العربي
[موسيقى]